[Musique]
ça faisait sûrement arriver vous êtes
sur internet vous consultez vos sites
préférés vos applications et là vous
voyez apparaître une publicité de
chaussures de scotch de vélo ou de frigo
exactement le modèle ou la marque que
vous aviez rechercher la veille 1 à qui
la faute en fait ce sont généralement
les témoins de navigation ou les cookies
en anglais qui génèrent ces choses là
c'est hazard lé ces témoins sont de
petits fichiers que les sites inscrivent
dans votre fureteur et vous suivre
partout vous allez en ligne rendant
possible la publicité dit cibler mais
d'où vient le terme cookies c'est son
inventeur l'informaticien américains
nous montrent aussi qu'il a popularisé
au milieu des années 90 quand il
travaillait chez netscape les
programmeurs utilisait déjà le mot
cookies qui désignait un paquet de
données que s'échangent des programmes
informatiques entre eux leterme aurait
comme origine le fameux biscuit chinois
qui contient bah oui le petit message à
l'intérieur là c'est traces que vous
laisser en ligne c'est un peu comme les
miettes d'un biscuit que vous laissez
derrière vous en mangeant elles
permettent de vous suivre et de vous
suivre partout c'est le même principe
c'était moins ont été conçus pour
faciliter le fonctionnement du web tout
en permettant aussi de mémoriser des
visites des utilisateurs les témoins
ordinaires rendent possibles des achats
en ligne le fait de conserver vos
préférences sur un site ou de reprendre
une vidéo là où vous l'aviez interrompu
par exemple mais certains servent aussi
à la publicité on les appelle les
témoins tiers des sites comme google
facebook et tant d'autres vous attribue
un témoin tiers quand vous naviguez sur
leur plateforme témoin qui vous suivra
partout à la trace ensuite 17
commerciaux qui ont des ententes avec
django vous enverrons alors des annonces
ciblées en fonction de vos habitudes de
navigation
traçable grâce aux témoins tiers donc
vous deviner les témoins tiers sont
source de préoccupation en matière de
protection de la vie privée parce qu'ils
impliquent des tiers parfois inconnus et
s'exécute à votre insu ou sans votre
consentement en plus les témoins de
navigation peuvent être potentiellement
détourné des pirates informatiques qui
peuvent reprendre le contrôle des
comptes et voler les données
personnelles des utilisateurs mais une
chance il ya des solutions vous pouvez
refuser des témoins tiers en vous
rendant dans les paramètres de votre
navigateur naviguer sur le web en mode
incognito en navigation privée peut
aussi être une solution et en plus de ça
on peut prendre le soin de supprimer les
témoins quand on ferme le navigateur
autres pistes de solution il ya des
outils des extensions qui s'intègre aux
navigateurs et qui permettent de les
réduire aussi plusieurs entreprises
évoquent la possibilité de remplacer les
témoins par autre chose pour conserver
la publicité en ligne source de revenus
pour bien des entreprises tout en
protégeant un peu mieux les internautes
mais ce n'est pas encore clair ce qui
pourrait se substituer aux témoins c'est
donc à suivre certains états comme la
californie et des entités comme l'union
européenne ont légiféré sur la vie
privée la protection des données en
ligne ce qui passe notamment par
l'exigence d'informer les internautes
sur l'utilisation des cookies et
l'obtention de leur consentement morale
de l'histoire la vigilance est de mise
en attendant que les autorités légifère
pour mieux nous protéger et que
l'industrie développe des outils plus
performants
[Musique]